une évaluation sur l'efficacité des
contrats aidés ils se sont aperçus que
cela n'a pas d'efficacité sur sur le
chômage que finalement je suis tout à
fait d'accord mais le fait de les
supprimer oui voila apres c sur l'
économie sur le fond voilà qu'elles font
et la famille c'est toujours pareil
c'est facile pour équilibrer le budget
la suppression des contrats aidés nous
avons aussi poste à l'école nous
aujourd'hui nous avons nous rend passant
par des personnes plus ou ne sont plus
aidés n'oblige et ne le supporteront pas
il faut se battre nous il faut qu'on
fasse en fait on soit didactique on
explique qu'on explique mais de la
pédagogie la pédagogie
pas toujours simple parce que même nous
parfois
les choses pour comprend groupe